Good evening, and welcome to
Tales of Sweet Grass and Trees.
I'm Robin Kelsey, and I'm
Dean of Arts and Humanities
here at Harvard and
co-convener with my colleague,
Ian Miller of the Environment
Forum at the Mahindra
Humanities Center.
And it is my distinct
pleasure to welcome you all
and to introduce
tonight's event--
which, by the way, we would have
put into Sanders Theatre had we
known what the demand would be.
So lucky you, to have a seat.
I'm going to begin by
giving some thanks.
This event is
co-sponsored by the Center
for the Study of World Religions
at the Harvard Divinity
School and the Mahindra
Humanities Center.
And I want to thank
Charlie Stang, the director
of the Center for the Study of
World Religions, and his staff
for doing so much to
pull this event together.
I want to thank Homi Bhabha,
the director of the Mahindra
Humanities Center, his
executive director, Steve Biel,
and their staff for all
their support of this event.
And I want to thank Ned
Friedman of the Arnold Arboretum
and his staff,
especially Pam Thompson,
as well as the emeritus,
but still quite vigorous,
professor Larry Buell, without
whom this gathering would not
have come about.
There are moments that one
wants to hold in suspension,
not because one doesn't
want to see them unfold,
but one simply wants to
acknowledge how marvelous it is
that this moment has arrived.
And for me, this evening
is such a moment.
And I know the same is
true for Ian and Charlie.
To have these three
incandescent writers--
Robin Wall Kimmerer,
Richard Powers,
and Terry Tempest
Williams-- together
for a conversation about giving
voice and agency to entities
beyond the human is a
miraculous, tingling boon
for this community.
And I want to thank them
and to thank you all
for making this moment happen.
I'm going to offer brief
introductions of our visitors,
radically truncating
the prodigious extent
of their achievements.
May I say "truncating"
at this event?
[LAUGHTER]
I'm in trouble already.
I'm just getting started.
With each introduction, I will
offer a snippet of their prose.
And then I will
get out of the way.
Robin Wall Kimmerer makes
me proud to be a Robin.
[LAUGHTER]
A plant ecologist, she is
SUNY Distinguished Teaching
Professor of
Environmental Biology,
a member of the Citizen
Potawatomi Nation.
She is founder and director of
the Center for Native Peoples
and the Environment.
Her first book, Gathering Moss,
won the John Burroughs Medal
for Outstanding Nature Writing.
Her recent book,
Braiding Sweetgrass,
on the teaching of plants, has
been widely read and beloved--
I'm sure by many in this room.
If you are feeling blue, sit
and read some of the 519 reviews
on Amazon.
And the testimonials of
inspiration will give you hope.
Better yet-- read the
book, or read it again.
All we Robins may tweet.
But this bird has wings.
[LAUGHTER]
Sorry.
I don't know if it's
getting any better or not.
But all right.
In the chapter "Burning Cascade
Head" of Braiding Sweetgrass
Robin writes of the now
fragmentary accounts
of the venerable Nechesne
ceremony welcoming the salmon,
a ceremony marked by
caretaking and gratitude.
She writes about her own
walks on Cascade Head.
Thinking about this
ceremony, remembering it,
she writes, I drop to
my knees in the grass.
And I can hear
the sadness, as if
the land itself was
crying for its people--
come home, come home.
There are often
other walkers here.
I suppose that's what it means
when they put down the camera
and stand on the
headland, straining
to hear above the wind with
that wistful look, the gaze out
to sea.
They look like they're trying
to remember what it would
be like to love the world.
Richard Powers is one of the
great novelists of our time.
He has written 12 novels on an
astonishing array of subjects,
garnering innumerable
fans around the world
and many prizes.
To pluck just one
from his stash,
The Echo Maker,
his 2006 novel that
unravels from a car
accident in Nebraska
and mingles with
sandhill cranes,
won the National Book Award.
His most recent
novel, The Overstory,
is about the strange
powers of trees
and their entwinement
with humans.
It was shortlisted for
the Man Booker Prize.
Ann Patchett has called it
the best novel ever written
about trees and, really, just
one of the best novels, period.
In The Overstory Richard
writes, at the start
of the section entitled "The
Crown," about a man lying
on the ground at dawn
in the boreal north.
The man, with head sticking
out of the tent, asks himself,
what are those treetops like?
They're like that
cog-tooth drawing toy,
spinning out surprise
patterns from the simplest
nested cycles.
They're like the tip
of a Ouija planchette,
taking dictation from beyond.
They are, in fact, like
nothing but themselves.
They are the crowns of five
white spruces laden with cones,
bending in the wind as they do
every day of their existence.
Likeness is the
sole problem of men.
But the spruces put
out messages in media
of their own invention.
They speak through their
needles, trunks, and roots.
They record in their own bodies
the history of every crisis
they've lived through.
The man in the tent lies bathed
in signals hundreds of millions
of years older than
his crude senses.
And still, he can read them.
Terry Tempest Williams
is writer in residence
at the Harvard Divinity School.
Her many books include
the now canonical work
of environmental
literature, Refuge--
An Unnatural History
of Family and Place.
She has won the
Robert Marshall award
from the Wilderness Society
and the Wallace Stegner Prize.
Last month the Los
Angeles Times announced
that Terry would receive
the Robert Kirsch
Award for lifetime
achievement by a writer
with a substantial connection
to the American West.
Having Terry at Harvard
with us the past two years
has been splendid,
invigorating, catalytic.
In Refuge, she writes
of times sitting
on the shore of the
Great Salt Lake,
soon after learning that her
mother's chemotherapy has not
eradicated her cancer.
I love to watch gulls
soar over the Great Basin.
It is another trick of the
lake to lure gulls inland.
On days such as this, when
my soul has been wrenched,
the simplicity of flight
and form above the lake
untangles my grief.
Glide, the gulls
write in the sky.
And for brief moments, I do.
Hoping to glide and circle
this evening with these three
great writers, I ask
you to please join me
in welcoming Robin Wall
Kimmerer, Richard Powers,
and Terry Tempest Williams.
[APPLAUSE]
Yikes.
I feel sorry for all of you.
[LAUGHTER]
Deep breath.
Thank you, Robin.
What a tweet introduction.
[LAUGHTER]
Thank you, always, for your
eloquence and leadership--
merging of the humanities
and the sciences,
the social sciences,
arts, and religion.
Bless you and Ian
Miller for your vision
of the Environmental
Forum, an open door
to the environmental
humanities at Harvard.
And my deepest gratitude
to Charlie Stang,
director of the Center for
the Study of World Religions.
Without a vision of the
Earth as sacred text,
we are not being
responsible to the past,
to the future,
this present moment
on this beautiful blue
planet we call home.
Ned, thank you for
the work you're doing,
and for the conversation
you had last night
with Robin and with Richard.
I hope this is an
extension of that.
And my deepest respects
to Larry Buell.
Thank you so much for
walking point for us.
Two extraordinary guests--
they are my literary mentors.
They are teachers.
And the thought that I can
be here with both of you
is one of the most humbling
moments of my life.
Both of you shatter the violent
myth of human exceptionalism,
that we are the only species
that lives and breathes
and loves on this
planet here, now.
What you remind us over and over
again, every sentence, is we
are not alone.
The philosopher
Mary Midgley writes,
the ultimate act
of anthropocentrism
is to assume that other species
do not feel, do not suffer, are
not sentient beings.
If the taboo against
anthropocentrism
is being lifted, slowly, Robin
Wall Kimmerer and Richard
Powers are writing our way
toward a more inclusive future,
where community can be
viewed as all life forms--
plants, animals, rocks,
rivers, and human beings.
I see the work that
you do on the page
and in the world as a
redistribution of power.
As we learn to sharpen, through
you, our capacity to listen,
to see, to pay attention
to the living world,
to those we live among in the
plant and animal kingdoms,
we are beginning-- just barely--
to understand what native
people have remembered.
As Henry Beston has written,
these are not underlings.
These are other nations.
Welcome.
It is an honor to
be in conversation
with the two of you.
I'd like to dedicate tonight to
William Merwin, who passed away
on the Ides of March--
he would have loved that;
maybe he planned it--
one of our greatest poets.
I remember Mark Strand,
when he was living in Utah,
teaching at the
University of Utah.
We were at one of those
awkward gatherings socially.
And we were talking
about Merwin.
And he said, oh, Merwin.
He was probably our
generation's-- no,
he was our generation's
greatest poet,
until he started
writing about trees.
[LAUGHTER]
When I told William
that, he said, oh,
and if Mark had
only come to visit.
Ha.
Outsider art,
outsider literature--
we belong to this
tradition, too often viewed
within the academy as soft,
sentimental, and at times
nostalgic.
For those of us within the
Harvard Divinity School
community, we are especially
grateful to have you
here at this moment.
And many of us
view your presence
as fortuitous, as
auspicious, a blessing--
pick your word.
We need your wisdom.
And it would not be
honest if we did not
bring to the table
what we are facing.
As a frame for this
conversation, on Friday
the tree at the center
of the Divinity School,
the Divinity Tree,
is being cut--
a 150- to 200-year-old red
oak, deemed on the downturn,
with hollow limbs.
So says the particular
report from an arborist.
The question now is, what
do we do with this moment?
What is the nature of ceremony?
How do we bear witness?
And what comes afterward?
So here's my questions to
begin our conversation.
What are we afraid of?
How shall we live?
And as Dean Kelsey coined last
night in our conversation,
what is the politics
of the unseen?
Richard, you write, trees
stand at the heart of ecology.
And they must come to stand at
the heart of human politics.
So this is where we are--
a collision, a
collusion of values.
They are economic.
They are ecological
and spiritual at once.
I hear your voice--
why didn't you do something,
you who were there?
We tried.
Restoring land,
you write, Robin,
land without
restoring relationship
is an empty exercise.
How do we restore this
relationship, here, now,
at this place?
W.S. Merwin writes,
quote, I want
to tell what the
forests were like.
I have to speak in a
forgotten language.
So the question I would
like you both to address
is, what is the
forgotten language?
I think we should
start by acknowledging
whatever the right word
for the wrong word--
which is coincidence--
should be,
that Robin, I am just back
from Hawaii, and a visit
to Merwin's palm forest.
And Robin's on her
way there next week,
or two weeks from now.
Yeah.
Wow.
So, yeah.
Mm-hmm.
I went out-- can you
hear in the back?
No.
Taking technology into
my own hands here.
[LAUGHTER]
I feel empowered.
Better?
In the back?
Yeah?
Good.
So I said that I am
just back from Hawaii
as a guest of the
Merwin Conservancy,
and have just visited the
extraordinary palm forest
that he left us as
one of his legacies.
And Robin is on her way there
in a matter of one or two weeks.
I had the pleasure of spending
remarkable time with him
when I was younger.
And I had hoped to
see him on this visit.
And he was in his last days.
And company was not possible.
But I did visit the 11 acres
of world that he transformed.
He took spent farmland
on the island of Maui.
And over the course
of 40 years, 45 years,
he transformed it
into what may be,
by many measures, the most
extraordinary collection
of palms in the
world, or certainly
one of the most extraordinary.
And he did that more or
less single-handedly--
not to make it, but
simply to be planting.
He just did it every other day.
He just brought something
out and planted it.
As a result, they've ended up
with several thousand palms,
450-plus species from
all over the world,
just because a man
thought this would
be an interesting practice,
just to have something
to order his week and to make
him present to where he was.
The land was spent--
whatever that meant,
whatever that means.
And now it's like walking
through the world's palm
forests in the
course of 11 acres--
not unlike walking through
the Arnold Arboretum
and seeing these creatures
brought from all terrains
and all climes together
into a single place.
It's absolutely extraordinary.
And you'll see it soon.
But what interests me,
again, is this idea that--
this isn't science.
In fact, when the Conservancy
brought the scientists
in to look at the palms and tell
them, what is the value here,
they said, well, since
he wasn't especially
careful about provenance
and accession records,
we can't really use it
as a scientific tool.
Yeah.
It was never his point.
And it's simply one of the
most extraordinary spots
for being present to place
that I've ever stood in.
I'm eager to stand
in that place,
and to feel that
power of presence
and the power of a restoration
of healing spent lands,
and that presence.
I also would like to respond
to your question, that
brought tears to my eyes that
you should ask, what are we
afraid of?
What are we afraid of
that Merwin was not
afraid of, not afraid of in that
act of replanting that place?
And I worry that
we are, at root,
afraid of acknowledging
the grave mistakes
that we have made, the
grave underestimates
of the sentient beings
who are around us,
of imagining feeling that
wound of knowing that we are
surrounded by intelligences.
Let me see if I can--
let me just do this.
Is that OK?
Yeah.
That we are surrounded
by intelligences
other than our own that we
have dismissed, harvested
as if they were commodities,
as if they were just stuff--
I think that we're
afraid of the pain that
will come from that and a
pain of the humbling that
comes from that, of
acknowledging the mistake
that we've made.
To not realize that we are
surrounded by our relatives who
have cared for us all along,
and that we have reciprocated
their generosity and
their care with blindness,
I think that's one of the things
that we're deeply afraid of.
And so we maintain this posture
of human exceptionalism.
We create arguments
and rationales
for why these others need
to be under our control,
that these others
are our property.
And I think that's
what we're afraid of,
is the pain of acknowledgment.
And with the advances
in science that
are coming fast and furious, I
can't think of a single study
where anyone has proven that the
world is dumber than we think.
[LAUGHTER]
Right?
And we are approaching
that time of reckoning.
And it's deeply
interesting to me, how will
we react when we all
come to recognize
the intelligences
that are around us,
and the disrespectful,
dishonorable ways that we
have interacted with them.
Robin, you mentioned that
we're afraid of the grief.
We're afraid of
feeling something.
I remember one of the last times
I was with Merwin and Paula,
my brother had just passed away.
And when we met--
I've known William for 30 years.
And he looked at me and
he said, what's wrong?
And I told him.
And I started to weep.
And he just held me and
said, I know where to go.
And he took Brooke and I to
this particular precipice.
It was a beautiful
ledge, one of the folded
cliffs he writes about.
And we just looked
out over the water.
And he never said anything.
We just watched the water-- the
waves, the erosion, the birds.
We just immersed
ourselves in this place.
We went back to their house.
And Paula and Brooke were
talking in the living room.
And William said, come
to my study, which
was this inner sanctum.
And I walked in and
he shut the door.
And I just sobbed.
And he just stood
there and let me.
And then he looked at me with
those steel-blue eyes and he
said, this--
this is the place we write from.
Never forget, this is
the place we write from.
Is it?
[LAUGHTER]
So we are afraid of dying.
And I think consequently,
we're afraid of creatures
that are so much larger
and older than us.
And to think about a tree, an
individual bristlecone pine,
that's older than writing--
it's a terrifying thing.
To think, like
Frank Kermode says,
that we were born in
the middle of things;
we live in the middle
of things; and we
die in the middle of things--
that's not a good story.
[LAUGHTER]
So there's this impulse to make
sure that no one else gets out
of here alive.
To some extent, we take
revenge on creatures
that seem to have a much more
integrated and continuous
existence than we do.
And I think that's a
small instance of being--
if you grow up in a
culture that tells you
that there is no meaning
except the meaning
that you make for yourself,
it's terrifying at first
to think that there might
be meaning out there.
And I think the impulse
toward mastery and the impulse
to control starts
in that sense that--
I'm going to die, and all of
this is going to keep going.
But I've been told
that the only meaning,
the only access to meaning
that I have is my own life.
I want revenge on
everything out there.
I think there's an
element of that in the way
that we've reduced
other sentient
beings and other moral
agents to resources.
And I think that that's
coupled with our great desire
to continue to see
ourselves as in control,
on the top of everything.
And it's kind of an
immortality project, I think.
I think you're exactly right.
And what is that place that
we write from, and tell
those stories?
Because that place that holds
that really deep well of grief
is, for me, the same
place that holds the joy,
and that they are partners.
And so yes, we write from
the tension of that place.
And I think, to tie these
threads together, that notion
of being afraid to become
part of the Earth again,
that ultimate
reciprocity, that--
for me in the worldview
that I inhabit--
there is that
sacred time when you
get to become the humus, the
root of that wonderful word
of humility, of human and soil.
To me, that is a place that I
want to live in and write from,
too, that place of humus,
and the willingness
to be part of that, to feel
my whole self interdigitated
with all those lives
that came before, like--
I'm sorry, I'm a botanist--
like root hairs penetrating
those air spaces, you know?
Yeah.
So in saying that, it
reminds me that we either
think that the world is a source
of belongings, all for us,
or it is a most profound
sense of belonging,
where we came from
and would return to.
I love in your chapter
"The Three Sisters"
how you say they should
be writing the story.
It should be them
who tell this story.
And then in another chapter
you talk about, it's
all about the pronouns.
Could you talk about
those two things,
and weave them together?
Yes.
If there are scientists in the
room-- and I know there are--
and heck, any just speaker
of English, the notion that--
especially in our scientific,
technical writing--
that we must "it" the world,
that these beloved teachers,
these sources of
knowledge for us,
we can refer to only with great
distances, is to be objective
and to call them "it."
Whether we're doing
technical writing
or whether we're
speaking English,
we have to "it" the world.
And just to bring that
home, I would never
say of my dear friend, it is
sitting at the table right now.
Right.
Right?
I'm sorry.
I mean, that's rude.
I've taken something
away from you
and made you no different
than this table.
And that is, in English,
how we are constrained,
aren't we, to speak of the
living world, that we "it"
nature?
We have no other way to do it.
And it strikes me as the
perfect language for capitalism.
Oh, yeah.
There's a moment
in my story where
two people are doing a tree-sit
200 feet above the Earth,
in a giant redwood
that's slated to be cut.
And they're holding
a perpetual banter
with the cutters,
who show up every day
to see if these folks are
still sitting up in the tree.
And at one point the
cutter says, come on down.
We can talk about it.
We won't hurt Mimus.
And there's this instant when
the people up in the tree say,
ah--
we got them to call
it by its name.
Step one.
Yes.
Richard, in your
characters, we see
where they begin, where
you start these profiles.
And we see the
transformation and how
they're all drawn to trees--
Right.
By the end.
And they are transformed.
We as readers are transformed.
I'm wondering, as the
writer, were you transformed?
Oh, my God, yeah.
I mean, the reason I wrote these
nine road-to-Damascus stories
is because I couldn't
get mine out of my head.
I went from being absolutely,
ridiculously tree blind at 55
to the worst kind of convert.
[LAUGHTER]
And you know there's nothing
worse than a recent convert.
No, it was pathetic.
[LAUGHTER]
And I mentioned this last night.
I couldn't tell an
ash from an elm.
Forgive me.
Robin's heard this, and
Terry's heard this already.
I knew what a maple
looked like, you know.
But I also put sweet gum and
sycamore into that category.
They were just
strange-looking maples.
And I would see a tulip
poplar and say, wow,
what happened to the
top of that maple leaf?
It was just a blur.
There was a frilly
green blur out there,
that was occasionally
aesthetically pleasing
but purely functional.
To this moment of a-ha, which
happened to me because I
happened to be standing
in front of an escapee,
up on Skyline Road above
Silicon Valley in the Central
Peninsula, that was 30 feet
across and 300 feet tall,
and almost as old as Jesus.
I'm not proud of the fact that
it took something that size
to effect this conversion.
But once the conversion
was underway,
everything, everything,
everything changed.
And I went back out east,
to the forests and the trees
that I had grown up
near and thought I knew.
And the most banal thing was
now a mystery, and painful.
You say, what are we afraid of?
We're afraid of deep feeling.
We're afraid of being vulnerable
in the face of something
so magnificent.
And I kept reading, if you
want to see what an eastern--
I was immersed in this research.
I read over 100 books on trees.
And the sudden
realization that meaning
was out there changed
everything that I read.
And I kept reading
that if you want
to see what an eastern
forest looked like,
an eastern broad-leaf
forest looked
like before the
crazies got here,
you had to go to the Smokies,
because there's still
120,000 acres of uncut forest
in Great Smoky Mountain National
Park.
And I went down there four years
ago as part of my research.
And you don't have to be
capable of seeing too much--
as you walk up from a
second-growth forest
into an uncut forest,
into a primary forest,
into a forest that looks very
much like it probably would
have looked like
10,000 years ago--
to see the difference.
I mean, the quality of
the light is different.
The sound is different.
The smell is different,
species count is different.
And here I was for the
first time, thinking,
this is what my forest--
this is what a functioning,
intact forest looked
like everywhere in my country.
And I'd never seen it before.
And eight months later, I was
still thinking about that.
And I went back.
And I bought a house.
And I've been living there
ever since, full time.
And you say, how does that
road to Damascus change you?
It used to be that my
sense of worth in the world
was contingent upon my writing
a thousand words every day.
If I didn't do it, I would
start that slight sense
of existential panic.
Am I going to
remember how to do it?
Is it going to be there
day after tomorrow?
Am I a decent person?
Have I paid my rent today?
Now, if I don't walk four
miles, if I don't get out there
under these trees,
it's not a good day.
My sense of what I see
and how I want to see it
and what constitutes
time well spent
is entirely different now.
Thank you.
You know, Robin, I'm reminded--
you talk about the
redwoods, these big trees.
And I'm reminded of the story
you tell about moss, seeing
this moss on the stone.
And you were so excited and
impassioned, both braiding in--
as you do so eloquently--
what it means to be
a Potawatomi woman,
indigenous roots, in
place, also a scientist.
And one of your students said--
and I'm going to
paraphrase this poorly--
but, is this your religion?
And you stop, and you
think, where do I go?
Can you share that with us?
And maybe, where do you
see your transformation?
Or how do you respond
to it, and that notion
that you were sharing
about kinship, kin, key?
Yeah.
I remember so
clearly that moment.
And it was in the Smokies.
Oh, wow.
It was above your home.
And my students and I
were both transfixed.
We were there in spring.
And Copeland got it right,
about Appalachian Spring.
Oh my God, yeah.
Only these two could
have gotten me out
of this place in the spring.
[LAUGHTER]
Two days before leaving
I was on the trail.
And there were two dozen species
of ephemerals on the trail.
I know, I want to follow you.
[LAUGHTER]
We should have held
this talk there.
We still have snow
on the ground.
No, but in that moment when--
I was teaching at a small
college in the Bible Belt.
And so when a student asked
me, is this my religion,
knowing that there was a
huge gulf between our ways
of understanding that, I
just really hemmed and hawed,
as you might imagine.
It was also my first job.
[LAUGHTER]
So I thought, I probably ought
to be a little careful here.
But is it?
Yes, in the broadest
sense of that word,
of the sense of
belonging and meaning.
I'm glad-- I'm always glad when
anybody asks me about moss.
Ha.
[LAUGHTER]
But you could say, about moss,
what you just beautifully said
about your forests, of that
sense of unending mystery
and curiosity that is present
in a tiny little moss forest,
and the spiritual practice
of being on your knees
to see these beings, the
fact that you don't see them
if you're not paying attention.
You don't see them if
you're walking too fast.
You don't see them if you're
in your head all the time,
and always looking up for
things that are bigger
and more powerful than you.
But when you take the time, it
is that same rush, euphoria.
I've been doing
this for decades.
And I still get that
same rush of mystery,
of entering into a
world that isn't mine
but is so fully inhabited
by these beings who know all
about what it is to be a moss.
They are fully present
and being in place.
They are little
sovereign green beings.
And it is always humbling
just to be in their presence.
It's a kind of awe
that we usually
associate with the
grand, but is, in fact,
present at the
miniature as well.
You talk about mushrooms
and the Pottawatomie word.
Can you talk about that?
Oh, I'd love to.
And the Pottawatomie language,
of which I am a very beginning
student, has some, for
me, words for things
that we do not have in English.
And for me, one of the most
powerful of those words
is associated with that
little bed of moss.
Be on your knees, come
into that little forest.
And you look, and there's going
to be a little mushroom pushing
up from there.
And [INAUDIBLE],, a
wonderful ethnobotanist--
Ojibwe woman elder-- she
gave the word for that.
The word is [NON-ENGLISH].
And it means the force that
causes mushrooms to push up
from the Earth overnight.
And as I've written, that
that is the moment that I knew
I had to learn my
language, because
of that power of observation.
Not only of-- the word isn't
for the mushroom, is it?
It's the word for a
force and an energy
and an agency that
animates the world.
And since then, I've
learned that there
are other words for these forces
that Western science does not
even have language for.
We might explain the
mechanism by which it works.
And oftentimes,
as scientists, we
confuse knowing the mechanism
with knowing the meaning.
But our ancestors did
not make that mistake.
They named the
forces separately.
There is a force for sap rising.
There is a force for
that which propels
the opening of buds into leaves,
for all of these mysteries.
You know, back to
this word "religion,"
I'm not sure what it would
have meant to your student.
But it means something
for me to remember
that the etymology of that word
means tying back together--
re-ligio.
Yes.
Like to ligate back together.
So insofar as being
on your knees in front
of the moss forest
is a reuniting of you
and something else, then
it is a religious act.
Amen.
And I love that tying--
Brother.
That tying together, it makes
me think of the mycelium--
Yeah.
In the forest floor, when
you see that white connective
tissue, almost like lace.
And when I read your
piece, that word,
I really experienced it
almost like a fist coming up
with that fruiting
body of the mushroom,
knowing different
people have moments
with the gifts that are theirs.
And this force, this resistance
insistence, all of a sudden I
started thinking about
community differently.
I started thinking about how
we're connected differently.
And in your book,
Richard, for me,
one of the most powerful parts--
and I think about, again,
this politics of the
unseen and the seen--
is this resistance insistence
that your characters emerge in.
And what do we do with that?
There's that haunting
scene with Patricia,
where she's asked
the question, what's
the most important thing
we can do for the Earth?
Can you talk to us about--
and I have to be honest, this
is a difficult one for me.
And we're friends.
My brother hung himself in July.
And we had a very candid
conversation in April.
And what he said
was, I have the rope.
And when someone you love says
that, you take that seriously.
And we did.
We talked about it.
And he just said, Terry,
the world is fucked.
I'm fucked.
And you're in denial.
And you've got to let go.
You've got to let
go of the Earth.
You have to let go of me.
It's over.
And I remember saying to him,
I will never give up on you.
I will never give up on the
Earth, because of that force,
because of the mycelium
that holds us together.
And in your book, here is
this powerful character
who brought forward the
notion that trees communicate.
And then she was chastised,
thrown out of the academy.
And in this moment, in another
lecture out of another time,
can you talk to us
about un-suicide?
This is the question, as your
reader, I want to ask you.
And unfortunately,
we're doing it publicly.
[LAUGHTER]
Well, everything is
done publicly, right,
because there's always
something listening, right?
The story of Mimi Ma's father,
and the inexplicable suicide, I
got from a dear friend.
And her father also told
her, I have the gun.
And I think the bewilderment--
and again, the etymology
of that word is crucial.
The return of our state to a
wild state, the bewilderment
that we feel in the presence
of someone else's hopelessness
is unanswerable.
And if I did not now
believe that meaning
was out there, and not
simply living and dying
with us each individually,
I would be your brother.
But you reference the work
that Patricia is involved in,
the recent discovery
that trees in a forest
are richly and robustly
connected underground
by fungal intermediaries,
and sharing both sugars
and hydrocarbons and
secondary metabolites
in a kind of massive
Medicare for all--
[LAUGHTER]
That you cannot undo.
It becomes much more
astonishing when
you realize, as Suzanne
Simard then demonstrated,
that Douglas firs are doing
resource sharing with birches.
And as we learned from
Paul [INAUDIBLE] yesterday,
the oaks are doing
it with pines.
Any sense that we have that
it's every individual for itself
out there, that it's a
competition among ruthless
individual forces, is
completely laid waste to
by this vision of
massive interconnection.
That notion of "we"--
that we are not alone and we
are nurtured by each other,
is a powerful
sense of resilience
in the face of stress.
And we know that these networks
have evolved and been created
in response to, how do we deal
with shortage, with stress,
with those things
that propel undoing.
And the answer is that
we rely on each other.
We share.
In thinking about the
evolution of mutualisms,
it has been shown
for some organisms--
lichens are the ones
I can speak to--
that when you put together
those two symbionts of a lichen,
and you put them together in
a laboratory atmosphere which
has everything that
they need, when
things are abundant they give
each other the cold shoulder.
They have no interest
in symbiosis.
When you stress them, when you
start to take everything away,
something happens to them.
And they know that
they need to team up.
And that's when lichens form.
That's when lichens form.
And to me, that's a powerful
lesson of the resilience that
comes, and a lesson for a time
of climate change and resource
shortage of our own
making, that what
does the world say that we
should be doing in this time?
Isolating one another?
Reveling in individualism
and cutting off our ties
to one another and
to the natural world?
Of course not.
It says, come together.
Come together.
And both of you have
to bring your gifts
to the table in a just way.
That's right.
And I take that as a
lesson for our time.
There is no environmental
issue that's
separate from issues of justice.
No.
And that's un-suicide, right?
That's someone saying-- the
ultimate source of power,
of narrative is that
word "nevertheless."
That's where all our
stories come down to.
It all ends.
It all changes.
It's all lost.
Nevertheless, for a
moment, we are here.
And for a moment, we are part of
a community that we can't even
see to understand.
I love that line--
be still and feel.
We don't do that enough,
Well, and we're back to
Robin's act of attention,
which requires getting
down on your knees.
And I said this yesterday, too.
Robin's books profoundly changed
me as I was writing mine.
And in particular, it
was this realization
that the power of
stillness is also
the power of magnification.
And Robin points out
this astonishing thing
in Gathering Moss, where the
relative sizes of mosses--
if you go from the ones that
are closest to their fundament
to like a shining clubmoss or
something that towers inches
high above the
base, that ratio is
the same as the ratio between
a blueberry bush and a redwood.
So if I wanted my redwood, I
could stop, magnify, and see it
in the clubmoss.
And I have a trail
near the house--
it's one of the closest
to my house, Chestnut Top
on the north side of the park.
I call it the Robin
Wall Kimmerer trail,
because the first
300 yards of it
is just a magnificent treasure
trove of non-vasculars.
It's just the perfect
breeding ground for it.
And sometimes I feel driven to
get up to the top of the ridge,
and get up into the pine oaks,
and keep moving and seeing
the world from up above,
and getting that big view
across the ridges.
Sometimes I never make it
out of that first 300 yards
because there, in a
patch 18 inches across,
is a whole forest
within a forest.
But that requires stillness.
The audience-- you
have been still.
And let's open it up for
questions for the next 30
minutes.
So it just flashed into
my mind that the stillness
that you were advocating, and
the nevertheless-ness that I
was advocating are both
in that word "still."
We hold still, but still.
[LAUGHTER]
Yes.
Questions?
Yes, and we have someone
that's helping us.
There's a question in the back.
Thank you so much.
I've noticed an immense
amount of kindness
that you share when
you speak to each other
and when you share your stories.
I've also noticed that when you
describe the plants and trees,
you have this kindness with
which you use the words.
And I've also noticed
there is a shift when
you speak about people.
And there are two questions.
One is, what kind of
self-kindness practice
do you have in your life?
And second is, I'm wondering
if to be able to see kindness
in trees and in
nature, one needs
to cultivate self-kindness
first to be able to share it,
to be able to see the
same beauty in people,
with the same magnifying
glass and with the same kind
of silence and pause.
Thank you.
Thank you for that
question, which
just has my mind reeling
about kindness and the way we
experience it and give it away.
First, to your question
about self-kindness,
I'm reminded that in
our creation story,
sweetgrass is the
bearer of kindness.
It's always the one who is
there to come in, to fill
in empty places with kindness.
And so in our teachings, it
is a property of those plants
to bring that to us.
I think in reflecting
on what feels
like almost an implicit
question, of speaking of plants
with kindness and maybe
of people less so,
is for me the notion--
and again, it's held
in our language.
The same word for berry, of
berry plants, of which there
are many, the word is min.
And it's the same word as gift.
And so we understand the plant
world as a bearer of gifts,
one of those gifts
being kindness,
the other gifts of
food and medicine
and beauty and teachings,
and all of those.
And in a sense, plants
give their bodies away
in these acts of generosity,
reciprocity, and kindness.
But those of us who live
in an animal body, who
can't photosynthesize, we
can't give our bodies away
in that same gifting sense.
So the kindness, the gifts that
we have to give are different.
They might be the
gifts of stories.
gifts of creativity,
of restoring the Earth,
of science, of art.
And so I think that notion of
kindness, and self-kindness,
is to remind ourselves
of what our gifts are
that we have to give
as well, and to nurture
those gifts the way that
plants nurture berries.
That's, I guess,
what I'd like to say.
I have to say that the
biggest gift that I received
while writing this book was
a kind of honorary membership
into the world of plant people,
because they are remarkably
generous and gentle, in a
way that I was not before I
wrote this book.
The other capacity that your
question asks about, that is,
demonstrating that also to
large mammalian bipeds, that's
been trickier.
I went to the woods
to live deliberately.
[LAUGHTER]
Somehow, I knew you'd say that.
Have to say it.
I've heard that.
But also to get away.
I mean, I was in a rough spot.
And having 800 square miles
of wilderness in my backyard
was very attractive.
And I would pick the trails
based on how little chance I
had for seeing other people.
And I gradually did get my
feet back on the ground.
And it's a lovely figure
of speech, right--
so that the ground
could come up into me.
But my friends and
family would say,
aren't you afraid, being
out 9, 10, 11 miles down
a trail without
having seen anybody?
What if you run into a bear?
There are two bears per
square mile in the Smokies.
And I always wanted to say,
it's not the quadrupeds
I'm worried about.
It's the guy in the
camo who's coming down
the trail in the
other direction.
But enough conversations with
enough of my own kind out there
really did open my eyes
to a lot of things.
People want something that
they're not getting now.
And if we are mean to each
other, if we're angry,
and if we do exceptionally
cruel things,
it's often because of
species loneliness.
It's often because
of solastalgia.
It's often because we
are just so homeless now.
And that's why, in my book, one
of the characters is called--
it's too difficult to set up.
But she begins to hear voices.
And the voices are telling her
the most remarkable creations,
the most remarkable
creatures need your help.
And she pursues this
as a defense of trees,
these often 1,000-year-old
creatures that are operating
on these unfathomable scales,
with infinitely complicated
behaviors.
And it's only through
a series of reverses
and reveals that she
realizes it's actually
the humans that need our help.
That's not giving too
much away, for people
who haven't read the book.
But that's been my
journey, as well.
And full disclosure--
I'm really angry.
And with a name like "Tempest"--
[LAUGHTER]
I'm going to move now.
So I may look kind.
But I'm really not.
And the way I
rationalize that is,
I hope that I can take my anger
and turn it into sacred rage.
And I think that's why I write.
And I'll never forget--
I have a dear friend,
Willie Grayeyes,
who's a Navajo elder, Dine.
And after Bears Ears was
gutted by Donald Trump, 85%--
these are lands sacred to the
Hopi, the Navajo, the Zuni,
the Ute Mountain Ute--
I went down to where he lives.
And I said, Willie, what
do I do with my anger?
And he said Terry, this
is not the time for anger.
This is a time for healing.
And I'm really struggling.
I'm angry about
the Divinity Tree.
I'm angry that I
couldn't do something.
I'm angry that
it's being killed.
And I don't know where
kindness comes in.
I'm trying to be gracious.
I don't want to
lose another job.
[LAUGHTER]
I've only been here two years.
Can sacred rage also be a gift?
You're trying to
give us something.
I think we have to come to
grips with who we are and who we
aren't.
And as a Westerner, I am seeing
my home ground raped, razed,
whatever metaphor
you want to use.
And it's hurting the people.
And it's hurting the animals.
And it's hurting the plants.
It's destroying community.
And I have to gather my energy.
And to me, the kindness comes
in the form of a fierceness,
that we can be fierce and
compassionate at once.
And we can't do it alone.
But here, and this, and this--
things are shifting.
And we can change our pronouns,
in both the human world
and the wild.
Question?
OK, I want to thank
you all for this,
and for acknowledging all of
these really profound thoughts,
and for acknowledging
the anger that many of us
feel about the Divinity Tree.
And I don't know how
to ask this question.
But how do we forgive
ourselves for not doing more,
and for not being
able to do more?
This collision of
values is really
sticking with me, because I'm
in the political life here.
And my days and nights are
one long collision of values--
human, human exceptionalism.
How do we forgive ourselves for
letting these things happen?
Can we?
I have to say--
and then to my friends.
I love that the dean of the
Divinity School, the first act
he and Louanne,
his wife, did were
take acorns to the arboretum
and propagate them.
That, to me, is a
gesture of forgiveness.
That, to me, was
a gesture saying,
there is going to
be another future,
given where we find ourselves
here at Harvard University.
And to me, those
seeds, those acorns
are the beginning
of forgiveness.
And can we have enough faith
at the Divinity School to give
them the ground they need to
propagate, and not replace it--
as Ned, you were saying--
with a big tree that
then fills the space?
Can we live with that open
space we have created,
and believe that 200
years from now, there
will be other people
that follow us
that can put their hands on
that tree and close their eyes
and feel the power of this tree?
To me, that is an
act of forgiveness,
and as a community to
come together and say,
it's not over.
When the tree is cut,
when the Divinity
Tree is in the chipper,
as Rosetta has said,
we need to face this.
That's just the beginning
of who we really can become.
And in that forgiveness, in the
planting of the acorns, to me,
the word "restoration,"
the healing,
the way that we as human people
can participate in healing
in the physical landscape.
But I'm reminded of our friend
Gary Nabhan's wonderful words,
that when we do ecological
restoration, which
might be the
beginning of healing,
we must also do re-story-ation.
And in my brief
visit to the tree,
and to stand in the
circle of people
who care so much about
this, and to feel
the reciprocity of
emotion between the tree
and those people,
I think a wound
that was very palpable
for me is the lie that's
told, the story about that
tree, that it has to come down,
et cetera, et cetera.
But what I mean is
that it's the story,
the re-story-ation
where the healing lies--
not only in the
physical restoration,
but of telling the story.
We have so many monuments around
this country to what we uphold
as the great and the good.
I think that we need
monuments to wounds.
We need monuments to stupidity.
We need monuments to arrogance.
And that's a re-story-ation,
to say we were wrong.
It's back to we're afraid
that we're doing wrong.
And we are.
And we should commemorate that.
We should remember this,
and then plant the oaks.
But I think we need to tell the
truth about that story first.
[APPLAUSE]
Yeah.
Nothing to add to truth as
a necessary prerequisite
for anything to
happen, except to say
that I've been on the
road now for almost
a year for this book.
And everywhere I go,
there's a Divinity Tree,
every town that I stop in.
And the people who
come up afterwards--
they don't really want
their book signed.
They want to say, this
is what happened here.
And I've completely surrendered
to listening to those stories,
for as long as it
takes in every venue.
Whether it's Sheffield,
England, or Los Angeles,
somebody has got something to
say about a crime that's still
underway, a crime caused by
anger and pain that hasn't
been acknowledged or named.
And that's why I
think naming it has
to happen first, before
there can be any healing.
Is there a student
that we can hear from?
Yes?
Merwin, in one of his poems,
"For a Coming Extinction,"
writes, tell him that we who
follow you invented forgiveness
and forgive nothing.
And he goes on to
write, the bewilderment
will diminish like an echo.
And I wonder, following
Merwin, whether questions
of forgiveness or healing
are already too late,
and whether we have the tools
to recognize that lateness.
The short question
being, do we have
the analytics to realize that
perhaps it's already too late?
I think we certainly don't
have the analytics to calculate
"too late," because
we don't even
know what we'd be too late for.
In other words, the
history of life on Earth
is the history of one thing
becoming another thing--
transformation, endless,
endless transformation.
And whatever happens
to us, it's not
going to be too late
for what becomes.
We can never make a calculation
on the effects of anything
that we do.
And so we're thrown back on that
fundamental ethical requirement
of simply being present
and being engaged.
Yes?
We have some questions
over here, as well.
Yeah?
Thanks.
All three of you
are operating from
and coming from a really
beautiful paradigm
of belonging.
And you talked about the
other paradigm of belongings
as a shorthand.
And I often wonder about--
it's kind of a teaching
and learning question.
What is the fastest route?
You're all writing, which is
a beautiful teaching for each
of us as individuals.
But I wonder, what
do you think is
one of the faster routes
for helping us as humans
change paradigms?
How do we teach that?
And maybe we don't
need speed, right?
I mean, recovering slowness
may be essential, too.
Yes, because when I think
about slowness and stillness
of trees, and all the plants,
one of the things that strikes
me about that-- in
response to your question--
is that the stillness of
trees honors relationship,
that if you're going to stand
in one place for centuries,
you have to be really good at
connection and relationship.
You can't run away.
You can't flee.
You can't say, oh well, I
used this whole place up.
So now I'll go
wreck another one.
So that notion of stillness and
the investment in relationship,
of making a home, I think,
is an important way.
I also want to say
that of course,
we all wrestle with
exactly that question.
And one of the things that
I try to think about a lot,
because when I feel my own
powerlessness against Monsanto,
when I feel my own powerlessness
against these forces that
are arrayed against us, you
can go to despair, right,
and feel, how could we do this?
But I think that the one thing
that I do have in my power
to change is how I think and--
I was going to say what; I will
say, who I love in the world.
And that change in
one's own being, to say,
this is what I stand for.
This is how I see the world.
I see the world as kin.
I see the world as belonging.
But if I only say that to
myself, if I only feel that,
and feel alone and isolated in
a world which is falling apart--
the medicine is to
share those thoughts.
The medicine is the story.
And we all are story makers
around our own dinner tables,
with our neighbors,
and with our students.
When we give each other
a vocabulary and a name
for the world that
we love, we create
something which
has the potential
to be magnetically beautiful
that people will migrate
to that way of thinking because
it's so deeply satisfying
and cultivates a
sense of belonging.
Since we're sitting
next to each other,
we'll maybe just
ask both questions.
Thank you, each of
you, for your sharing
and your vulnerability
in public.
Richard, you said once the
conversion was underway,
everything changed.
And my favorite part
of Braiding Sweetgrass
is about the storying of the
throwing out of the coffee
grounds.
Ah.
[APPLAUSE]
From which, when I read
the book for the first time
a couple of years ago, I
developed my own daily ritual
of sharing my first water
of the day with the Earth.
And this discovery-- oh well,
there was no meaning, there
wasn't any special
meaning behind it.
But the wondering is
about how to get ourselves
in the way of these initiatory
moments of conversion.
How do we get our
babies in the way
of these moments of
conversion, at which point
everything changes?
Because if we can do that
for hundreds of thousands
of millions of people for
whom everything has changed,
that's part of the answer.
And so wondering about,
what are the ways
that you see to
make that happen.
I'm going to take
literally, how do
we get our babies into
ritual and into process
and into attention, and
say maybe the question
is, how do we make
sure not to stop them?
I mean, every child
is a naturalist,
and feels that animism,
and feels that connection,
and believes that they're
a part of these processes,
and looks at them intently.
It's the gradual accretion
of this other message--
that no, just take
care of yourself--
that breaks that down.
So it's really a
preservation issue,
how to keep them going
for as long as possible.
Yes.
And part of that
is, for me, also the
where, where does it happen?
And to be in the
presence of the teacher,
and to me that is in the
presence of other beings.
It's being in the woods, on
the prairie, by the water.
And I don't in any
way mean that that
has to be nature out there.
How many conversions
happen in the backyard
with a tree who you love?
How many conversions happen with
the moss in a sidewalk crack,
when you realize that there are
creative, courageous beings all
around you who are
living with you.
I think it's to be
in the presence.
But you also have to know
that you're in the presence.
Great, thank you.
I feel really moved
by the kindness
you're showing each other, and
the discussion of spirituality
in science and how that's
all woven together.
And I'm wondering how you
manage to survive academia.
[LAUGHTER]
Did we?
Because I'm
considering academia,
but having some questions.
They're all looking at me.
[LAUGHTER]
I haven't.
I am now [INAUDIBLE]
But I love-- my greatest
joy, my deepest joy
is being with students.
Yeah.
I mean, yesterday-- was
it yesterday, Monday?
We had four of the most powerful
stories I have ever heard.
And as we sat there around
the table, 18 of us--
what do you do with that energy?
And the only thing we
could do was to go outside
and to breathe, and to
howl, and to say I love you.
That's how we
survive the academy.
[LAUGHTER]
And what I love is that
we have an arboretum.
We have a divinity school.
We have the humanities.
We have the sciences.
We have scientists who are
coming to the Divinity School
saying, we know how
to handle the data.
We're really good at what we do.
What we don't know is how
to deal with our emotions.
What are the tools that
we need to handle our joy?
What are the tools we
need to handle our grief?
Where's the mycelium?
That's how we
thrive in academia.
We make things.
We make things together.
My brother died
because he was alone.
I have to live with it.
But he's still here
because, as you've
heard from both
Robin and Richard,
we just keep changing form.
Peter, I look at your art.
It's the fabrics creating
collage, creating landscape.
We just keep
creating, each of us
in our own time with
the gifts that are ours.
That is the academy.
We can have these conversations
here in this Environmental
Forum, and go out and be
enlivened, enspirited together.
I want to go to your university.
[LAUGHTER]
Is there someone in
admissions I can bribe?
[LAUGHTER]
I think that's a
really good way to end.
[LAUGHTER]
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.